- Well Jenny seems like a special
lady, how did you propose?
- I, we proposed, I went,
took her to Catalina.
You know where Catalina Island is?
- [Sharon] Yes.
- [Kelly] I've never been there.
- There's nothing there.
(crowd laughs)
- Oh well so I probably won't.
- There's nothing there.
- I probably won't do it then.
- I don't work for the
Catalina tourism board.
There is nothing there.
- Buffalo.
- There's a bunch of buffalo.
They left after they shot a movie.
- What?
- Yeah that's really what happened.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Yeah so we went out to Catalina
and I had a diamond in my, the
you know that little pocket on your jeans?
- Oh the tiny, tiny one?
- I had the diamond
ring, yeah, and of course
this is the most expensive
thing I'd ever had,
was in my jeans pocket.
Other than like a Saab 900S in the 80s.
So, I was real
nervous, and almost I seemed,
I guess I seemed kinda mad
because I was just like
walking and like clutching
the thing and like freaking out and like
don't lose the Saab in
your pocket, you know.
And so, she thought that
I was bringing her to
this garden to break up.
- Oh no!
- Yeah.
Yeah, and she was super surprised.
- Wait, do people bring people to
beautiful places to break up?
- Who would do that?
- Yeah.
- And then my next
thought was she was like,
"Oh this is great news."
She started crying.
She's like, "This is great
cause I thought we were breaking up."
- Oh my God.
- And I was like, "If I
brought you to an island
(crowd laughs)
to the top of a hill, that's
like what Dr.Evil would do.
Mwahaha.
- You're either gonna
propose or bury someone.
- Yeah of course.
Look down the hill.
- It's fine.
- Surprise.
- How did Ozzie propose to you?
- Oh, he asked my father permission first.
Yeah he did.
- What a gentleman.
- Yeah and then he went
out and got me a ring,
but he got me a wedding
ring, not an engagement ring.
So, he bent down, he gave me
the ring, and it was lovely.
And then, the next week
we had a huge fight.
I took the ring off.
I threw it into the bushes.
- A very passionate relationship.
- Oh, yes, and then all
I see is my husband's bum
as he's on the ground looking
for the ring in the bushes.
- Did he find it?
- Yeah, he did.
- Good.
- 37 years later, it worked.